the veterans community care program is a
program that's ran through uh your local
municipalities
and it's for veterans who's had run-ins
with the law
and instead of going through the the
regular litigation or legal process they
offer you
um this judge control program it just
happened that uh Chris Lee from a North
Las Vegas judge Chris Lee
um he offered the programs to me I'm a
retired senior master sergeant Dexter
Taylor Dorsett Jr I am now a resident of
North Las Vegas
and the program
um did exactly what uh it was meant to
do I uh it Unearthed some things in me
um you know I had a drug and alcohol
problem that I was on my back for years
and
um through this program in some of the
um
the
community
uh rehab centers me specifically I went
to Vogue Recovery Center I was able to
tackle something that's been a burden on
my life for most of my adult life
um now if I didn't choose this uh I
could have a record I may have did some
jail time who knows what happens after
uh you know litigation is uh finished
and and totally brand
um it's it's it's process so
um
the program you know it demands that you
you know you stay clean you can't drink
you can't um use any type of drugs you
can't get into any more trouble you have
to have a job you have to check in once
a month basically you have a court date
once a month that you have to show up if
you miss that court date those charges
are then brought back on you and you uh
you know you're removed from the program
and you have to go through the uh the
the system per se and
um for me it was a total success
um I am a
a combat veteran who served in combat
tours um overseas mine specifically was
in the Middle East and then Asia
and um
out of my 24 years I would say about 15
or 16 of those were overseas
so living overseas as a military member
um
it kind of
I don't want to say you lose reality but
you you you pick up a different reality
than what you would be as a civilian and
then
all of a sudden you're released from the
military whether you're separated or
retired me I retired and I retired my
last day of work was March 2020. and you
know what that date is it kind of lined
up with covet
and uh it was not a great transition for
me um I went from the military to a
quarantine
the program was right on time I had no
idea that that was going to be a part of
my life
and um it helped me get back on track
and um
um restoring me to be a uh
I guess a productive member of the
community
um North Las Vegas is home I ended up
buying a house here again because of the
quarantine I had other plans I was going
to move to Costa Rica and uh retire
there but I ended up staying in North
Las Vegas after I bought a home so to
all those veterans that you know they
find themselves with court cases whether
it's in North Las Vegas or the Las Vegas
metropolitan area this program is
offered all through Las Vegas and I
imagine in all 50 states now I would
elect it because it's going to hold you
accountable it's going to make you uh
it's going to challenge some challenge
yourself and challenge uh some of the uh
Norms that you've set in your life but
at the end result
um you become a better person and that's
the most important thing but also that
court case that was hanging over your
head uh it gets wiped off your records
there's no trace of it it's totally
admonished and um
um that's a great thing too so I would
recommend this program to any veteran